the Joe Rogan experience what did you
think when they had that bare-knuckle
boxing event Paulie Malignaggi about
Artem Levin I loved off y'all go say
yeah yeah yeah sorry that's a that's one
of the more interesting cases because
you've got a guy in Paulie Malignaggi
who's a legitimate world champion and a
world-class boxer you know a few years
past its prime and hasn't really been
fighting yeah but then you see him fight
a guy like Artem Lobot who's used to
fighting with MMA gloves it's not much
of a difference fighting bare-knuckle
and blows off actually boys oh yeah
eating him in a decision which nobody
[ __ ] saw Pauly's not a puncher anyway
in my cell to go into that against a guy
that's naturally bigger as well but you
would have still thought of him enough
yeah that's a okay known enough you know
I could guy like Roy Jones jr. none out
boxing him you know I'm saying like if
some it's just like a world-class boxer
you would imagine even if he's a few
little tricks just to get it still gonna
[ __ ] you up
yeah just he's just gonna make the
adjustments yeah how he trained for it
God knows no idea you know I mean did he
box with bare-knuckle Rocky's I didn't
second round as well just really broke
it but because a few weeks ago when he
cause he's a pundit for Sky TV and the
boxing and a Yeti son still in plaster
or whatever it was then so it must be
bad many left-handed as well as me I
think yeah he had a bad right and they
never chopped right hands really any way
that he was always left under knee way
it wasn't young wasn't a lot of yeah
there wasn't a lot of like combinations
exchanged but that's the case with most
of those bare-knuckle fights it's a
totally different thing yeah he's
getting big in England not now as well
like the BKB thing having Big Show's
filling out big arenas if I can't look
got me done in London or two and stuff
now one of my friends fought on it
recently he's like getting a really big
name for itself well people like the
lease rules violence yeah the lease
rules possible they like it
you know like left way or you know
anything along those lines
you know headbutts with left way we need
take it to another level right yeah
that's crazy yeah come over to England
did some seminars on that with and he
was that boy in panthenol David LeDoux
probably yeah yeah he's got him coming
on the podcast soon
I I was a big proponent of no gloves
with MMA I was like well if you don't
have gloves on your shins and your knees
and your elbows well the [ __ ] do you
have money or not oh yeah I changed my
bed effect I think he's a car yeah yeah
that that's what the two worst things I
got caught four times on one eye and me
and after the fight because we had like
a bit of a war and I just died swinging
all over placing around free-trial KO
him I won't really pick him my shots
probably like I should have been I've
got bad problems with this one I've got
a metal plate with this one the day
after I flew back to England I went to
gym I put the girls on just to try and
hit the pads and I couldn't even make a
fist properly for about a week and half
two weeks just swell and couldn't yeah
it felt like all my wrist like tendon
Sensurround he wouldn't squeeze a fist
properly we're awful but not my own
stupid fault like when I was chasing the
fight I won't pick him myself properly
I'll just swing around in top of his
head and trying to ko him and it was
[ __ ] good yeah when I were in there
doing it you're just there but yeah it
is exciting we will miss they actually
he's gonna change the fighting I mean
which is I've learned that now as well
so
[Applause]